Ryan Reynolds the former sexiest man
alive has the best sense of humor the
actor is constantly flooded with not
safe for work comments in his Twitter
mentions and shuts down fans sexual
tweets with the best jokes I will come
up with something spectacular here's all
Ryan responds to the online advances one
user wrote shag my wife his response no
I'm in Washington DC trying to broker
real change another acid s will start to
quote murder my vagina prompting Ryan to
hilariously sweet sorry just holding my
infant nice in my arms for her baptism
right now 1follower got very explicit
then Reynolds tweeted oops I'm just
helping my Nana take her diabetes
medication right now if you're wondering
what Reynolds white Blake Lively thinks
of all the harassment belong this down
yeah a fan took care of that question
Ryan says quote pretty sure it's my wife
riding most of those sounds like her as
for the couple's baby girl James
Reynolds the proud dad is not worried
about her reading the racy tweets in the
future wrote quote joke's on you we're
not teaching her to read boom